mirapolis c'est fini le parc de loisirs
proche de cergy pontoise a fermé
définitivement après quatre ans de
fonctionnement chaotique
les forains les derniers repreneur en
date n'ont pas voulu poursuivre cette
coûteuse aventure à la veille de
l'ouverture de re disney laurence
thiriat c'en est fini de mirapolis
l'immense gargantua qui surplombe le
parc devrait faire ses valises et les
attractions être rangé au placard
construit en 87 en pleine folie de
l'industrie des loisirs en france ce
parc de 50 ha n'a pu remplir ses
objectifs de millions de visiteurs
étaient attendus chaque année ils n'ont
été que 400 milles en 2 ans mirapolis
avait accumulé 350 millions de francs de
pertes
le dépôt de bilan est alors annoncée on
parle de redressement judiciaire ou de
liquidation pure et simple
mais une poignée de forains décide de
relever les manches se constituer en
groupement d'intérêt économique mira
fait est investi 30 millions de francs
une somme encore insuffisante
il aurait fallu une enveloppe d'environ
100 millions de francs pour pouvoir
répondre à la concurrence c'est à dire
amener des attractions nouvelles pour
intéresser le public
il faut aussi savoir que cet espace a
été surdimensionné
c'est un parc régional qui ne peut
accueillir qu'une clientèle régionale
mais il a été conçu comme un parcours
européen s est énervé
il a été conçu
sur des études américaines pour un pack
fonctionnant toute l'année
il faut savoir que dans la région
parisienne un parc de comme celui là ne
peut fonctionner que 160 jours et par
contre il a les frais fixes de 360 jours
supposé révolutionner les moeurs du dic
des français mirapolis c'est un
l'arrivée d'euro disney n'ayant bien
surpris en arranger à la faire